good evening the back and forth battle
between the church and state during this
pandemic has been pretty tough when it
comes to covid regulations but tonight
churches have won a decisive victory
thanks for joining us at 11 i'm denise
valdez
good evening i'm brian loftis a federal
court ruling to change the capacity
limits at houses of worship in nevada
up to 25 percent orco mana on this story
he joins us live with
what exactly this means zorko
well brian and denise services at
churches like this one have looked very
different because of the pandemic
many of them happening online this court
ruling
is good news for some congregations but
many tell us
they'll still be playing it safe we have
lost a lot of people to this
to this to to colburn kelsey west is the
senior pastor at nehemiah ministries his
church has the proper social distancing
and sanitation measures in place but
because coronavirus has directly
impacted his congregation he'll continue
to only do virtual services
we're still able to do the work of the
lord
and i don't have to physically put
people in harm's way
this comes even as churches in nevada
now have new covet 19 regulations a
federal court overturned an order
tuesday that upheld limited gatherings
saying houses of worship can have 25
percent of their capacity
instead of the 50 person limit put in
place by governor steve cesalac
cantor jessica hutchings with
congregation near tamid says they're
also
fully online they even stopped parking
lot services when the statewide pause
was announced last month
we have a committee of doctors and board
members that make decisions based on
what our government is advising and what
is
safe for our community so we will be
meeting to discuss
how and if this changes anything that
we're doing right now
church goers we spoke to say they'll
continue to stay home
i'm afraid of what would happen
i think it's better to do it virtually
but i just want to be on the safe side
so right now i don't go to church
basically while some look forward to
in-person services during the holidays
pastor west has one simple message
this season i just want people to be
safe that's my prayer
governor sysolak said in a statement
that he was disappointed
in the court's decision but he will
follow it he's also still
urging congregations and churches that
choose to hold
in-person services to be safe by
requiring masks and strict social
distancing
reporting live in las vegas tonight orco
mana 8 news now